HE
IN AR  FOR WITH STUDEDEBTPRESID
IN FEDERAL STUDENT NTS
FOR BORROWERS THAN
LES O CNE HOUSPONDENT PHILTINGL.
EE WEEAT DAY?
>> THIS ANNOUNCEMENT HMONT.E BA.
ERREE KEY ELEMENTS HERE.
MPORTANT.
THERE ARE INCOMES TO
OR THIS LOANCANCELLAONOU ARE AI
MA25,000 A A
FAMILY THAR ,0
A  ANDOUE FEDERA THE P IY SIGN
T.
$20, CANCED FOPELL GRANTS THFEDS
THE ADMINISTRATION HAS WORKEINUO
S EFT
WH Y GRANTECIE0, LESOULD ALL.INO
ABOUT 43 MLIF NTAGE OFBEING PUTN
THE OTHER ELEMENT OFIS EXTENSIO
ER TO ALLOW THISN PLACE SINCEOFD
REGULATIONO TAKE ET.
FROM THE DEPARTMENT
EDUCATILL
YMENTS5% OF INCOME.
IT'S VERY
ISD .T, IT T
EVERYONE.
ME DEMOCRATS CALLED FOMO
REPUBLICY Y
ISETELY UNFAIRHOSE WHOLO
OFF,HOD AND SAVED FOR
D THON
ELENTS, CONCERNS ABOUT
INFLN EMOCRATIC
WHITE HOUSE LIEVE
OF THE
REPAT FREEZETH TANE
ING AGAINST ONE
ANOTHER.
THOSE AR THAE SIST THDN'T SEEM
KE>> MAKING IT IN JUST AE ER
WE'LL TADOESTHANYOU.
G US NOWS ELIZABETH
, THANK YOU VERY
MU JNG UKNOW
OAREEYO
LAW R STUDYINGHEEFEB FAMILIES.AN
0,U D 0,00
RELIEF.ATION TO
THIS PLAN FO$10,000?
AC IS THAT
R HAVEENT LOAN.ILMETHAT
WILL HAVIC OUDLOANS.
P FI
MOSTLY THE PEOPLE WHO HAVE S O
DENSOT BE  FOR WS HARDO
'LL SEE $20,00T RELIEF
FOR OVER H ALL OF THOWERS.
REALLYT , ARE DISPROCAN AMAN RTS
RELIE NEED IT
MOE ASK YOOUT THAT
THI
EQ
ACS STATEMENT IN RPOS
ANNOUNCEMEG THE STUDENT
SIS HAS ON BLACK
BORROWERS AND THEIR MILIES. A R
LOING TH
DEIO.RATION IS TR
LL
HAVIEEN SAID, THIS IS NOOM NAAC.
S TWO THINGS AB W NAARAM,HE TA.
CTS H LOANFO
ANE IONATELYL MINORI, RE
FIRST-GENERATION STUDENTS, THE
FACTY' TT  ICEL OUOF THEIR,
ALNAACR O HAVE MUDEN BEDOE TO FT
YES.
BUT THE STEPS THAT THENISTRAORE
L LIVES HAVET ER WT THEY HAVE
HOLE LOTENT.
>> ISN'T THIS JUST AAI
N HAND
T THTHE FIRST PLACE?
S
T.
CCEON WHETHER
DELIVERING ENOUGH S IN TERINGS.
>> SO, THINK T HAVE
THIN WOUT.T E ALREADY HAVEAN
CANCELING $20,000 OF TDEBT.PART
FIE D ER IMPORTANT
IS HE FEDERALVES OFFERING
W T TD CAN'T FOST WRITEECFO.
D  I TN'T HA
TO% OF TIR
THAT D DEBOUP
EY'RTH
ABLE TO PAR D PART IS ABSOLUTE
DOING O MAKE SATVERSITIES AN
FOHTSTUDTS BORMOO TO SCHD SO DO
THSCHOOLS,O THATVE REVEA ABOH
THEM AFT GATTH IND HOW MANY GRA
UN ACCOUNTLE A,  REIWE BY EVERY
TH AE
JUSTPE P DEBT.SAY  FAMILY THATAI
DIAVE THE RAGOVERNNT  OUT
AND NOW I Y BENG
FOR A FAMILY THAT AT SOM EARNINI
IS AcCLL
THE ONS ATCKG IT IS E IT IS , VY
G DEMOCRATS,EN
U BECAUSE ERE'S
ANODO
SOMEB NOT
STRUGGLING WITH EN
WAS TO TRYGE AFFRICK FOR IT. ONY
WHATE' D THATH
WE CAN I OUR PEOE.WE HELP OU.T A
SHOWS USS THAT BECSE
MANY PEOPLE WHO DO T MAMA'O SAV
BUSINESSES, WHO DON'AR.
LE.EME
AND WE H